so I'm here New Jersey to see if you've
forgiven Chris Christie I'm not sure
that Chris needs forgiving I think Chris
has been accused of a lot of things that
are probably not going to be true not
forgive you didn't do nothing wrong
to forget Chris Christie he's by bed I
have more respect for my opinion I you
know now that he faced the music does
this make you like me yeah I like him I
think he's an honest guy and tells it
like it is I like him I like his food
spa I think he's starting to show his
jersey side a little bit I see these
questions to see a Bowie is he there sir
he's that he's not a bully
he's from New Jersey that's that's the
way people in New Jersey operate a lot
of people don't like his style because
he's brash and in-your-face but you know
what it's a difficult business being a
public official it's complicated babe
you got to get a little more into
history books you got to go back a
little bit to the history of New Jersey
New Jersey politics has been this way
since the last hundred years you pay to
play if you don't pay you don't play
politics is just dirty it's very dirty
yeah the Tony Soprano will have the
reputation the mobsters you know from
New Jersey and they always take care of
the family just like the politicians the
Democrats they want to take care of them
across the Republicans they want to take
care of the public you can put 20
mobsters in jail and there'll be
somebody else right behind them to take
over the business same thing with the
politicians you can put them all in jail
and then there's always somebody that
comes behind them and there you can
never end it he didn't do nothing
different than any other politician
that's the politics today all politics
is corrupt
nothing's know it's been going on for
years hundreds of years and it's never
gonna change you make it so like this
whole bridge episode was good for Chris
Christie that's putting his name out
there I don't think the people in Kansas
could care less what's going on under
George Washington Bridge national name
recognition what more does a guy running
for a national office need but name
recognition and a media made him now
even more of a national figure than he
was before everybody knows his name now
do you think Cruz cuz he's given the bad
rap
chris is probably getting a bad rap I
think he's been a great governor and I'm
still standing behind
Chris you've been doing a fine job thank
you